Matthias: O.K. The annual meeting of the World
Economic Forum just closed here in Davos Switzerland.
I'm with you know [inaudible].
She brought you all those presidents and prime
ministers in front of this webcam.
And Pablo Camacho the citizen reporter from
YouTube.
We're at the World Economic Forum and I am
extremely grateful to all your contributions.
260 videos from the YouTube community and
to the 125 Davos participants who replied
to you videos and who joined the Davos debates.
It's amazing.
I think overall today I think 2.7 million
people have already watched these videos and
so it's a great success.
Now I can tell you that [Inaudible] has pledged
to bring these Davos debates to the G20 summit
in London which is absolutely great.
So I hope we can continue these discussions,
these debates here on YouTube.
So I want to thank you all.
I want thank also the people from MySpace
and [Inaudible] who was the MySpace reporter
here, and all the people on Facebook who participated
in the polls here for our annual mission.
So the debates are not over, the devates -- discussion
continues, even throughout the year at our
regional summits.
See you then.